okay it's the ninth inning the bases are
loaded we need a name for this puppy
true knowledge bat this games about cars
right what about cars the movie I'm
pretty sure that that's already a movie
of course I've got it drive club it's
perfect no no way that's actually
already a game in fact I'm playing it
right now come on people we've been
working on this cars project for years I
mean trying to think in this name for
six months maybe cars projects are just
impossible today damn this cars project
wait cars project cars project cars
project cars project cars project cars
I've got it gran turismo far as long as
there's been video games there's been
video games with dumb names like attack
of the mutant camels on the Commodore 64
or spankys quest for the snares but you
think that as the games got more
sophisticated so with the names well
apparently not like these titles that
are just too long for their own good
such as Warhammer 40,000 dawn of war two
retribution showing the world that you
can have both a colon and a hyphen in
your name and get away with it there's
also brain age train your brain in
minutes a day and its sequel brain age
two more training in minutes a day let's
be honest they're hardly remembered for
their brevity or for making sense at
least the power version was a bit better
but still a bit wordy but the title that
needs to tone it down the most is
probably 2006 s the Lord of the Rings
the battle for middle-earth to the rise
of the witch-king precious it is not
moving on then to the worst movie tie-in
game titles yes we get that you've got
to put the movie title in but give it
some pizzazz you know don't do a hurry
Potter and call it harry potter and the
deathly hallows part one the video game
I mean you can hazard a guess as to what
part 2 was called other dishonorable
mentions include the lego movie
videogame hannah montana the movie and
then there's the ego toss-up between Tim
Burton's The Nightmare Before Christmas
okies revenge and Peter Jackson's King
Kong the official game of the movie then
there's the game names that are just a
bit weird like shaq fu' and vvvvv thee
then there's the Parappa the rapper
spin-off um jammer lammy and then
there's the unpleasant and or sexy
sounding wet not one to be outdone
Konami brought back an obsolete word for
their 2013 hack and slash metal gear
rising revengeance and finally we come
to game names that just make you despair
while stalker may be a decent and
convenient acronym when you realize it
stands for scavengers trespasses
adventurers lowness killers explorers
robbers well that kind of takes the fun
out of it but at least it shows some
kind of originality unlike most games
with war in the title like tom clancy's
endwar war face war thunder and of
course medal of honor warfighter are
supposed to watch those walk
cuddlers come on guys what do you mean
gran turismo a long-standing racing
franchise with multiple entries across
multiple console generations for over 15
years there's a flagship car racing
simulator on sony playstation hung up
the phone harder damn it we're back at
square one plus we got that meeting in
the money club in like 5 m's good
pointer Rooney thought shower
congratulations everyone we got there in
the end and I'm sure we're all looking
forward to the release of Tom Clancy's
hazardous automobile wheel extreme or
hooks for short I love it
please mr. cloud tom clancy's harder
come on e this in school